buongiorno spettatori studenti essere
inferiore al dottore oggi dottore qua
per insegnare voi cose perché il dottore
patto scoperta molto importante come
vedere dottor sempre immersi studi
perché umanità dipendere da sottoscritte
torre scoperti dei piedi chiede servire
a essere umano per camminare dottore
credo siano i canneti dottore capito
male dottore scoperto dianetti pianetti
non solo essere coperti ma essere
abitabili o cito prove andare in
spedizione per avanscoperta macchia
netti essere già abitati da essere
inferiori chiamati station web dello
sport and leisure cotte legio questi
alieni sempre tutti in station back
andare a scoprire razza aliena e
spostare per fare spazio tatore flotta
servirle flotta è sapere valigia per
trasloco valigia fa eco cazzi sovviene
alice essere qua per trasportare tutti
tu menti di dottore chi essere questo
elemento è sbagliato e spedizione
contenuto principale mario necessitare
anche di indumenti valigia fischiasse
prego questa è sapere valigia tito torre
tutto necessario a quanto visto partire
subito fattore messo comodo postazione
per dirigere flotta telecomando
universale
gioco già presente dentro switch gioco a
parte primo step montare flotta lotta
qui presente per andare a distruggere
station wagon avere problemi staccare
toghe molto forte dove hai trovato
l'astronave e unirea flotta già
presentato inserire sony al contrario
passeggero inserito lotta pro vanta le
armi armi per potenziare flotta armerino
sbarre al laser 2 spara ghiaccioli
inserviente pulisce stiva lotta quanto
inserire joystiq.com dentro base per
navi cemento base quanta scienza molto
evoluta navicella 40 partire difficoltà
molto difficile perché il datore pronto
ad ogni sfida momento di
personalizzazione di navicella staccare
pezzo inutile e nel gioco scomparso
tutto io poter ricambiare in questo
momento precise anni dentro se davvero
care perso un pezzo perso tutto non
avere più disponibili italiani ed rs
perdere pure navicella ci hanno
attaccato chi sono essa per questi
station wagon male tech station wagon
come sparare a prevalere sempre nemica
web etto di guida preso in patatine
torre vince sempre vede nemico
l'approccio nemico distruggere i nemici
necessitare armeti forti in questo
momento è dottore cambiare pezzo di
astronave anno non cambiare adesso
perché essa c'è più ma dopo trova essere
molto più bello di quanto ci si
aspettasse grazie e sarebbe finito sul
pianeta necessitare cambio di pezzi
potrebbe uscire d'astronave tutt ora
essere straw nave pezzo scomparso nove
houdini altra pezza cosa montare su
affronare avere un sacco di pezzi
disponibili staccare da altro flotta
pezzi strani questo trovato a casa
raduno non è se avessi cupola di cosa
fare
probabilmente torte gelato pezzo molto
più grosso inserito pure quello
astronave fortissime necessario
colonizzazione prove contro tutte le
station wagon distrutto tutto i nemici
doveva scappare via essere questo capo
di station wagon dottore non è station
wagon e forgotten legio got away l'on
nel giorno cote legio essere nemici
questo non essere in grado neanche di
pulire ogni vestito nemico disintegrato
quello che succede quando si va contro
il dottor dito verso il nemico
eccolo nemico come verrà fatto a non
vederla necessità ricambio doppiare il
nemico quasi morto dottore vince a
pagare questo e come settore e fare
parcheggi e adesso dare un'occhiata per
fauna e flora di pianeta per capire se
facilmente colonizzabile niente regio
patente fuoco e patatine scadenti
dottore alzare atterrato su qualcosa le
aree attorno animale strano serra e
diventare utile per conquiste essere
unipol con iphone molto e anche un po
che come motore venire qua non scappare
da br il dottore
male non essere una vita animale non
sempre avere interessato di donne quale
affetto voler fatto volo incredibile
schiantato malissimo
creiamo mappa che controlliamo punto
l'ispezione questa essere rapidamente a
da colonizzare qua esserci qualcosa di
dare a vedere sperare di trovare
parcheggio avere trovato qualcosa filone
minerale comune raccolto strada per
arrivare appunto essere più lontana di
puglia lombardia pure scattate per
cambiare arrivato sul punto il cercatore
amico nemico amico amici trovato uccella
di gloria cote ammazza quanto e
sarebbero tre fronti
grazie per l'aiuto e andare a liberare
persone necessitare di benzina quindi
questa volta tutt ora aiuta la prossima
volta arrangiare lo so sapere di poter
andare un massimo 138 toma
infischiarsene in questo caso non poter
cambiare le armi per utilizzare punti
deboli di nemico magari subito armi
disponibili e utilizzare le fiamme
questa essere recalina perché
illuminarne
fatto distruzione totale di nemico dove
prende tutto torre tornare e ricevere
benzina aveva vissuto serbatoi e quindi
avere visibilità molto più grande su
tutto il pianeta punto di arrivo bri
nube questa essere nebbia di berlino per
cambiare ulteriormente armin 8 ottenere
qualsiasi momento di colpire tutto è
fatto malissimo dover saltare ogni volta
il dottore vince sempre e tira distratto
nucleo una lesione completa cadere il
tuo bacio pastore tedesco minore che
grosso di scansionare aver addomesticato
pastore tedesco seguire il dottore stole
tedesco veramente lenta quindi il toro
infischia fan esserci nemici ovunque
conseguirsi dove poter prendere
cosa ti serve poco dove sapere non
avevamo bisogno di consigli scientifici
stato reinventato senza ghiaccio
presente ghiaccio inserito rilanciato
sito elemento ambulanza per d'ottobre è
finito mi sia la sai tu molto bene
grazie
ambiente torna la signora progetto
consegnarle questo aver fatto pure
missioni secondarie ti senza sapere che
sarebbe programmato su una vicenda
principale azionista in chiave
potenzialmente non avere idea di cosa
aveva fatto mandatorio essere scienziato
quindi andare benissimo dover trovare i
materiali per imparare potenziale nave
mater dei motori ripristinati ancora
fortuna con la vostra ditta una bella e
bisogno di fortuna dove inventato
fortuna sfortuna essere elemento chimico
città volata reato il trovatore aver
visto starling van der pol atlas essere
veramente bello lasciato pianetta così
questa cosa e sarà incredibile per
tornare quando vuole
no questa cosa essere assurda dottore
aver dovuto provare per vedere cosa mi
piacere tantissimo 5.000 chilometri
lontano e serve fatto essere navicella
che il dottor aver imparato prima essere
meglio di meccanico
meraviglia tra le meraviglie bove
distruggere station wagon legione ex
vegan torre distruggere tutto e di non
andarci
ciò può essere veramente bello o calcio
e basket torre fatto cose strane
il per kuyt e essere guida veloce per
raggiungere pianeta visto qualcosa di
strano
attenzione spaziale dawn iperspaziali e
sarà in pericolo non vedere nemici non
scappare perché dottore aviv e di
pericolo stato flusso canalizzatore
dottore vede terra approccio pianeta
terra per trarre comunque
vendi cose stranissime carpet pianeta
sembrare molto molto differente da terra
dove avere sbagliato tutto provato
pianeta molto ospitale siccome trovato
pianetto ospitale dottore concludere
ringraziare voi spettatori e studenti
però devo imparare colonizzazione di
pianetta tutt ora avere giocato starling
sito già ovunque
adesso tutorial ritrovato pianeta molto
simile a terra dove poter non ascoltare
più canzoni di gigi d'alessio dottore
adesso fare riposino
no per tutti debole e chiude video terry
comando questo per comando propulsione
bella studenti
[Musica]